service skills und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen video leute heute müssen
wir uns mit den wirklich wichtigen thema
beschäftigen mir wurde in letzter zeit
öfters unterstellt dass ich selbst nicht
nur hacker zeige in der causa noch
selbst mit dem hacken zu tun habe
da gab es unter anderem ein youtuber der
versuchte mich zu basten war es nicht so
erfolgreich war aber heute ist der tag
gekommen an dem wir alle zweifel aus der
welt schaffen
heute heute testen wir ob ich ein echter
hacker bin
und dafür gibt es natürlich natürlich
wie für jeden anderen auch ein quiz auf
test.de bist du ein echter hacker von 22
31 und wir testen jetzt heute mal ob ich
ein echter hacker bin hab ich selbst sk
entscheiden muss ob ich nicht für sich
selbst entscheiden muss und der mir das
vorher nicht angeschaut muss auch dazu
sagen wir starten als blind reihe legen
los mit frage nummer eins was tust du
wenn du einen virus infiziert anti wie
antiviren programm anschmeißen
ignorieren was ist denn videos ist schon
sehr sehr kompliziert hier los ich weiß
ja nicht
habe ich eine antiviren skype ist doch
ein anti-viren-programm oder also wenn
ich mein gesamtes becker wissen jetzt
anstrengen dann versuchen nur lösung für
dieses problem zu finden
dann würde ich glaube ich dass andere
ihren programm an schmeißen alles klar
nächste frage was tust du wenn du lange
warst rausgehen pageplace ein bisschen
programmiert wird freunde bleiben
natürlich programmiert leute
selbstverständlich bisschen c++ hier bis
den kunden css da kein ding ausgehen
dass für diese dunkle für die denken
dass das im reallife wichtig ist hier
schon in meinem laden mit die rollladen
unten meine softbox stracke schon an
ihren tonne lampe die viel zu tief hängt
die lampe ist einfach hart direkt zum
mitten im zimmer nicht jedes mal ran
aber bei 3
was sagst du immer am pc der xbox hot
dogs cod wow oder gta und da muss ich
wahrheitsgemäß beantworten das ich
bisher noch nie
rottstock gespielt habe cod vor drei
oder vier jahren das letzte mal noch nie
gespielt aber wenig später
deswegen geht ja ok nächste freiheit
wenn du wenn du leute warum tust du mir
noch mal die aktion durch wände los los
los ich bin süchtig keine ahnung ob das
spiel ist cool ist okay das ist schnell
beantwortet und frage 5 vom hacker chris
wenn du hecken könntest was würdest du
tun gehabt hatten brücke natürlich
natürlich würde ich brücken hecken
einfach fucking gebäude aus stein die
keinerlei verbindungen zu irgendwelchem
internet oder stromnetz haben einfach
steine wortwörtlich steine aneinander
gereiht steine ja es sind fakten steine
die will ich natürlich hecken wird die
die backsteine hecken den beton würdig
hecken oder oder natürlich vorher
umlegen auf der polizeistation ecken a
ich hab mir schon bock polizeistation
von hecken aber rücken hecken mag da war
viel mehr spaß als polizist und wer an
sich auch nicht aber muss auch immer
aufpassen was mal super sagt wenn du
könntest würdest du mein chris packen
und daraus perversitäten machen alles
gar nicht so schnell dass auf jeden fall
acht jahre alt wenn er sowas park aber
ich bin natürlich auch acht jahre alt
dementsprechend würde ich perversitäten
aus dem quiz machen
das wäre voll machen muss frage 8 die
findest du das quiz bemerkt ihr einfach
wie im teilweise sowie satzzeichen
ausgehen hier
wir haben einfach hier kein fragezeichen
es hat ein so krasser heckert als seine
ganzen spiel points auf hecken
aufgewendet und hat dann leider keine
skateboards besatz zeichen mehr wie
findest du es kurz hallo
dieser ist ob die punkte hier rechts vom
de sind
ich würde echt nicht gemein seine echt
nicht aber diese rechtschreibung ist ist
schrecklich
hallo du bist ein doofer hallo xdd
jedoch dass es auch wirklich sinnvolle
antworten von denen vier die wm
die vorletzte frage leute kannst du
hacken ja klar
blüht jahr ein bisschen was ist dieses
hecken überhaupt alter easy free agent
installiert und dann geht's richtig ab
man klassiker leute wir noch eine letzte
frage
bevor wir zur endgültigen auswertung
kommen und ihr und alle welt erfährt ob
ich selbst teil der elemente sind
vielleicht stecke ich auch mit hacker
senf unter einer decke wie heißt wir
wollen die antworten
michael treffer gegen psg hat jetzt
unser taktik überlegen alles klar ist
die letzte frage wir wollen uns
natürlich jetzt auch nicht hier des
hackings bezichtigen empires ist so
offensichtlich dass ein hacker im
spielten dann kann man nicht wählen gta
hat eigentlich nichts mit helmut michael
auch gta auch nichts am hut aber eh zu
altair ezio auditore ich glaube niemand
hat weniger mit hecken am hut als
zweifacher auditore west ich weiß nicht
genau wann hat sie zugelegt
barack obamas geburtstag war johannes
takt ist ja das neue fit wird 1459 alles
klar okay
damit es dann auch bewiesen editor ist
all is fott deswegen www.ec und schauen
jetzt mal was das hacker quiz für uns
ergeben hat sind wir schuldig sind
unschuldig stecken wir mit hacker sind
unter einer decke okay leute die
auswertung und go fast ein guter hacker
wenn von zehn aufgaben richtig
beantwortet es liegt über dem
durchschnitt der durchschnitt 484
ausschied und ich bin fast ein guter
hacker
das heißt ich bin auf jeden fall schon
mal
heute glaubt diesem fest nicht das quiz
hat keine aussagekraft ich bin kein
hacker auch wenn das christus sagt ok
müssen vertrauen ich bin kein hacker
alle dieses gegenteil behaupten sind
lügner und alle anti plugins die mit
reporten auf servern sind auch lügner
und alle die mir beim hacken zu sehen
wenn ich nix wird kilo recke sind auch
leute die behaupten dass mein zweiter
count die zu sony co th dp heißt die am
recht